a primera vista la vida parece normal en
colombo la capital comercial de sri
lanka con su brillo moderno y próspero
pero desde hace meses el país se
enfrenta a una grave crisis económica
para verlo hay que alejarse del centro
de la ciudad y de sus zonas de lujo
según el banco mundial más de medio
millón de cirila en que cesc han caído
por debajo del umbral de la pobreza
desde que comenzó la pandemia la
situación está más grave que nunca según
el equipo de esta ong que ayuda a las
poblaciones más vulnerables ese día con
una librería móvil para los niños que
desertaron del colegio con la pandemia
se han perdido muchos puestos de trabajo
y eso también afecta a los niños la
inflación los precios de los alimentos
están subiendo la gente tiene que pagar
la electricidad del agua y el alquiler
aquí están entre la espada y la pared
tienen que hacer trabajar a sus hijos
para sobrevivir estas familias que
dependen de un salario diario están en
primera línea de la crisis actual y de
que se trata de una factura de
electricidad sin pagar desde hace seis
meses si pagan esta factura no podrán
alimentar a sus hijos
y aguantar hambre
eso es todo lo que voy a cocinar para
cinco personas en la próxima comida es
realmente difícil vivir en estas
condiciones el impacto de las sucesivas
restricciones y cierres de fronteras
relacionados con la pandemia se ha
dejado sentir en gran parte de la
población de sri lanka así como en el
crecimiento del país que se ha visto
privado de los ingresos procedentes de
las exportaciones y de los visitantes
extranjeros en la industria del turismo
que aportaba más del 10 por ciento del
pib de sri lanka al menos 200.000
personas perdieron su empleo de la noche
a la mañana este es el caso de navy per
era chef desde hace 20 años ahora
intenta resurgir como puede en un sector
muy afectado por la actual subida de
precios
normalmente en un restaurante tenemos
menús folletos panfletos para hacer
publicidad en el exterior pero en cuanto
se imprimen los precios ya han aumentado
y las tarifas antiguas nos hacen
funcionar con perdidas
es muy difícil porque todos los precios
están disparando en sir lanka todo
aumenta ir a un restaurante es ahora más
que un lujo incluso las necesidades
básicas se han convertido en un look
desde la reapertura de las fronteras los
turistas extranjeros han comenzado a
regresar pero los trinan quest es aún no
están fuera de peligro la inflación de
los alimentos que lleva varios meses en
aumento acaba de alcanzar un nivel
récord del 25 por ciento esto se debe a
las malas cosechas ya la actual
incapacidad del país para financiar las
importaciones por falta de divisas el
pasado mes de abril el gobierno prohibió
de la noche a la mañana los plaguicidas
importados para luego dar marcha atrás
en su decisión esta brutal medida ha
tenido un fuerte impacto en la
producción agrícola de ser y la ncaa muy
dependiente de los productos químicos y
ha hecho que los precios se disparen la
gente ya no gana lo suficiente para
llevar una vida decente esta es la
triste realidad la gente se sacrifica lo
que antes compraban 500 gramos de
verduras ahora solo compran la mitad se
ha vuelto muy complicado ahora me caen
cinco euros de verduras en esta pequeña
bolsa no queda mucho en esta bolsa con
un elevado gasto público un menor
crecimiento y una enorme deuda externa
de 35 mil millones de dólares si la ncaa
tiene ahora uno de los de deuda más
altos del mundo y desde que las agencias
de calificación rebajaron la deuda
soberana del país por temor al
incumplimiento las arcas del estado
insular están más vacías que nunca china
tiene una fuerte presencia en el país
sobre todo a través de un importante
proyecto portuario y contratos de
construcción y es uno de los pocos
países que sigue prestando ayuda
financiera seri lanka la deuda con china
representa casi una cuarta parte de la
deuda total del país
cuando le prestan dinero a uno lo
vinculan a los activos se aseguran de
recuperarlo a través de las
exportaciones
por eso la ayuda china va de la mano de
la llegada de productos importados de
china todo el mundo quiere ver primero
el dinero antes de hacer negocios con
cil blanca la verdadera quiebra es
cuando todo el mundo pierde la confianza
en uno cuando nadie quiere adelantarle
nada ni darle crédito así que la quiebra
está a la vuelta de la esquina y eso es
exactamente lo que está ocurriendo en el
granca en este momento es
que al borde de la quiebra si la banca
se enfrenta a la escasez de productos
esenciales como el combustible lanzar es
un doctor de tuk tuk y tiene
dificultades para llegar a fin de mes
[Música]
en este momento es difícil para los
clientes y para nosotros porque tenemos
que pagar más por nuestra gasolina
tenemos que aumentar nuestros precios en
consecuencia para mantener la viabilidad
pero para los clientes sus precios son
demasiado altos es un círculo vicioso
con la comida el gas la gasolina más
cara y menos clientes lanzar se plantea
ir a trabajar al extranjero todo lo que
ganamos lo gastamos en nuestras
necesidades básicas es muy difícil con
hijos que mantener así que si puedo
estoy dispuesto a ir a trabajar a
singapur al igual que lanzar uno de cada
cuatro civil aunque se es afirma querer
abandonar el país en la oficina de
pasaportes de colombo las filas son
cotidianas la inmigración económica es
fomentada actualmente por el gobierno
que espera beneficiarse a corto plazo de
los ingresos de los millones de cirila
pnc heces que trabajan en el extranjero